joining me now to talk about a campaign
for the mayor of henderson dan stewart
thank you for joining us dan well thank
you john for having me it's a pleasure
to be here currently of course on the
henderson city council uh
first question why do you want to be
mayor well i think
probably most important two things even
most importantly is i think we've we've
reached a critical point in the growth
and evolution of our city
that i think we really need some
sophisticated
thought and planning
to uh to take us into that next step but
most importantly
i've got to tell you i want to uh
lead the charge in taking back control
of our schools for the city of anderson
and we'll we'll touch on that in a
moment i know it's it's an issue not
only yourself but your your opponent
in the race is mentioned as well but you
mentioned you're at sort of a critical
point for the city of henderson
what
is the
what kind of a path would you like to
see charted for the city when it comes
to the development when it comes to
making sure that
the city continues on the track that
it's on now or do you see a different
track well that's where i think is
important that we make sure we are
totally and completely transparent and
we get the input of the
residents now because
they have every right to be involved and
have a big say in the way we go in in
the path we take but
for me it is to keep the hometown feel
that we have right now that we've built
over the last 30 or 40 years we really
it's a fabulous community the leaders
before us
the folks officials have really
really made a great community but we're
at that kind of critical point to where
do we want to continue that way do we
need to grow how how is that growth
going to take place do you feel like
with the growth of
west henderson
obviously we talk about green valley and
all the residential developments there
on the south end of the beltway
is henderson losing that neighborhood
feel that you're referring to i don't
think so i i think that we can maintain
in fact i know we can maintain that
that neighborhood that community feel
uh and still yet grow and become that
more sophisticated community that we
need to be so how do you do that in
terms of what projects come in what
businesses you bring in what is what
does that look like well
as i've said
we're a great community lots of good
things have been done so we have the
foundation to continue that growth
but it needs to be done in a very
strategic
thoughtful way so that we can be very
selective actually in the businesses
that we try and attract and folks that
we try and
come and be part of our community
that can share our vision sure
you mentioned the school district you
started a pac i believe
yeah there's
you are uh
determined to separate henderson school
district for henderson from ccsd
uh
why
well
the easy answer
which is the truth is ccsd is just too
big it's just become
unyielding it just
it's we can't get anything done it's too
big
the
it's just a morass of
red tape and we need to have local
control
parents need to be able to be more
involved with their own with their own
children and their in the children's
education and the only way to do that is
to make school districts smaller
um
you're not the only person who's brought
this up this idea before there has been
an effort by for years to separate ccsd
and obviously uh council member romero
has brought this idea up as well
why is there such a push in henderson to
be on your own from ccsd well i think uh
i think we've reached that again i hate
to keep using that word that critical
point i think pandemic has kind of been
the straw that broke the camel's
camel's back i think there's so much
frustration amongst parents that people
are just in the outcry that we've got to
have more control yes you're right john
this has been something since
my kids were going to school i'm a ccsd
product my kids are a ccsd product my
grandkids are a ccsd product so i
understand this but we've been talking
about it and talking about it and
talking about it's time to do something
about it how do you do something about
it that's it's not like you can just
like flip this
it's going to be hard and arduous but
i'm up for the task we've we've started
the pack
community schools initiative
and uh anybody that
wants to help us we need all the help we
can get can go to community schools
nevada envy excuse me community schools
nv is our website but it's going to be
long it's going to be hard but it's
worth the effort and
it'll either be it will be done through
initiative the ballot or through the
legislature
you've discussed uh the issues of
transparency when it comes to growth you
discuss the effort to separate ccsd
from ccsd
i spoke with councilmember romero you
know of course and she brought up
many of the same things
so if i'm a voter why would i vote for
you instead of her because i'm actually
putting together this pact i'm actually
raising the money to
make this happen to go out and get this
necessary signatures to get this
initiative qualified it's just not an
easy process
like you said
you know snapping your fingers it's a
long process but i've started that
process with this
with this pack with this committee
and we are moving forward we're going to
get it done and it's the only way i know
of doing it is taking it to the people
getting the uh getting the initiative
qualified and then getting the
necessary signatures
just to elaborate a little more if
possible on
how
you
as the campaigns go on how do you plan
to differentiate yourself from your
opponent considering if you look just
sort of you know one against one a lot
of your positions are pretty similar in
terms of your vision for the future the
economic development aspect the school
district aspect public safety there's
not a whole lot of difference is there
so how there's huge difference so tell
me about what they are the perspective i
have been 40 45 years in this valley and
i'm a businessman i come from a total
businessman's point of view business
person's point of view excuse me and we
you know that perspective is necessary
to get these hard things done
and
perspective is everything i come from
the taxpayer i come from a customer of
government i've worked through
government and the red tape my entire
life so there is a huge difference
between a public sector
point of view and a private sector point
of view which my point of view is that's
where i come from why do you believe for
the overall city of henderson a private
sector viewpoint is best
i think because it's the way to solve
problems i think that the private sector
in the past has always been able to step
up
and able to
well let me let me let me put it in a
little different way my my strength my
strength i believe is being able to
bring people together
get a consensus solve the problems move
forward and i think the private sector
does that a lot better
is there a place for government
absolutely i'm part of that that
solution as well but at the same time
you need that perspective the business
person's perspective
on how to get things done
how much of mayor march's
agenda and the current city council sort
of uh
way of maybe thinking or the way the
votes have been going etc
how much of a change from the current
course of action do you anticipate if
you become mayor
is it status quo or is it okay i'm mayor
stewart
we're going to chart a little bit of a
different course here um that's that's a
very good question i'm not one to come
in and
wave my arms i'm saying we need to
change we need to change i think we need
to course correct a little bit how so
just elaborate that a little bit more if
you can again back to that point of
becoming a little more sophisticated
what does that mean sophisticated i know
what it means but like in terms of city
development
uh
sustainable growth not just sustainable
growth but and development but it's a
sustainable community how do we
continue to be the henderson that we are
and that we love and we love being part
of
but how do we anticipate and plan for
the future growth growth is coming we
just need to make sure we do it in the
right proper way
so you ask the question how do we become
sustainable in terms of growth what's
the answer
smart intelligent
thinking and planning
and
collaboration with the right kind of
people and attracting the right kind of
businesses
uh final question just sort of the
number one priority in your view for
henderson moving forward
take control of the schools
our own schools that's that's my mission
that's what gets me up in the morning
i'm passionate about it uh we're going
to make this happen and that's just not
for henderson this is for the state of
nevada i think for the especially for
this
southern nevada
we it's not just for the kids in
henderson it's for the kids and the
students throughout southern nevada it's
just got to be done ccsd is too big
we need smaller school districts just to
quickly follow up on that again we've
seen recently the issue at lamping
elementary in henderson
what is the correlation in your view
between what's happened there in the
last since school started essentially
and what you want to try and do can i be
personal can you use a personal example
my daughter lives in omaha there are
smaller school districts back there
they in one week because their school
district's smaller and they have better
control and one week they decided are we
going to wear masks or we're not going
to wear masks all right right now you
couldn't get that done in
you know with a buy-in from everybody
so i think with
the smaller school district
better control
parents more involved parents are the
key to a child's education and so
smaller school district
affords and allows people parents
families to become more involved and
therefore get the solutions quicker and
better solutions all right well good
luck on your campaign sir we look
forward to talking with you a little bit
later on appreciate it well john thanks
for having me it's been a pleasure